welcome back everybody cnn being
criticized rightfully for the softball
treatment of joe biden during the
interview last night
it comes in stark contrast to the way
president trump has been treated the
past
four years remember take a look you're
not wearing your big boot anymore
how is your foot and what happened your
third run for president
uh and you made it you made it
what does it feel like she and doug
amhoff which by the way is he the second
gentleman is he the second dude what
should we what should we be calling him
the term has evolved into the second
gentleman the second gentleman okay
i'll call him honey
what's your favorite flavor and cnn's
don lemon
using the interview to praise joe biden
and attack trump
it feels like we are watching interviews
or
president-elect and a president who are
on earth 1 and earth 2.
was very normal very stayed very sedate
and it was welcoming uh news it was good
to watch
we heard no fake news we heard no
conspiracy theories we heard no
personal grievances yeah i mean there
certainly was a lot of
the right answers there just wasn't the
you know
attack it was so sedate that i was
falling asleep there
judge bureau remember when they were
accusing the president of the united
states with absolutely no
evidence of being a spy for the russians
for goodness sake judge
yeah yeah you know being a spy for the
russians uh putin puppet
and all of that and never ever admitting
in the end that they were wrong and that
there was no basis
never taking the task the individuals
who stood before them
and said i have evidence like adam
schiff
or even people in the fbi never took any
of them to task and you know i got to
tell you geraldo the saddest part of all
this
is that you know we had a sitting
president who was 74 years old
who had coven and we understand that the
older you are
the more serious it can be okay when
when you
are that age they could have cared less
they didn't even believe he had it
they there were all kinds of theories
and the this this
vice president-elect uh you know
trips his foot allegedly playing with
his dog or breaks of fractures that i
don't know what he did
and they're all concerned about him but
not president trump
you know it's it's not their humanity is
nowhere to be found
they wanted biden and they got him in
he's their guy it's that simple
but you know jesse with the the press
being
an urban elite uh overeducated uh
you know based on one coast or the other
generally speaking maybe a couple of
them in chicago
uh they will never give a republican a
fair shake
and particularly not this republican
don't you think
i agree that i am overeducated geraldo
um and you're right i did some digging
and
found trump's first interview after
winning in 2016
by leslie stahl and here were the
questions leslie stahl asked president
trump
she asked about birtherism she asked
about the street protests against him
she asked when he's releasing his tax
returns and then she didn't even ask
she stated that blacks and muslims are
afraid of you
that was the interview and you cut to
something like this and it's like
what do you feel about having lunch with
kamala
on a weekly basis i didn't learn
anything from this interview the only
thing i learned was that joe fractured
his foot
chasing his dog and i learned that he's
not going to punish
china for covid19 and i learned that
everything he does is going to be really
expensive
i wasn't impressed by joe biden's
performance and i have to tell you
geraldo
i didn't think those cnn guys afterwards
were impressed either
you can tell not even cnn is impressed
with joe biden
but you know greg maybe uh the country
has to be in a cocoon maybe that's the
best
uh place after all of the agita we've
had
maybe everybody wants to be sedated to
use the word that don lemon did
you know uh um it was interesting when
uh when they when
when uh jake asked how his foot
he said how was his foot and joe said it
tasted funny
that was weird
[Laughter]
i'm just really happy that don lemon
is emotionally okay because that's what
this is all about
forget that trump trump started no wars
there were no body bags coming in
he was just he just made don lemon feel
so uncomfortable and he's so
mean and rooted now we have a really
boring guy who might start wars
here's you know the difference between
the behaviors
right of the media be with trump and
after with joe will be so stark it's
going to be like a drug ad for
psychosis you know before before biden
they'll be scratching at their skin and
eyeballing the ceiling and shrieking at
cats
and then afterwards they'll be licking a
lollipop on it
in sunshine and a swing built for two
and it'll just be perfect it'll just be
before just before derangement after
derangement
emily do you think it's a honeymoon with
the press or do you think it will be
forever do you think they'll always be
uncritical supremely sublimely
uncritical of the president
i mean you know me and usually i'm an
eternal optimist but i have to say that
i think this is going to be
a forever honeymoon and it just
terrifies me because you guys there's
there's two things that it covers up
right the good things and the bad things
so the fact that the media is unwilling
to ask
even even challenging questions even
critical ones
you know they don't they don't have to
attack the next president in the way
that they have
this administration to elicit factual
important information and to have that
administration be transparent which is
what we all deserve
because we pay the salaries of everyone
in office
but that is how things like
congressional slush funds
get set up because there's no
accountability for that and also it
covers up
the good stuff so if they continue this
if they don't ask the kind of questions
that elicits the real answers
then come time for the next election
they're not going to be able to say with
specificity or with that historical
accuracy
all of the good things that the next
administration has accomplished
they are shooting themselves in the foot
well there's no
doubt that the way to get good press in
the trump administration was to attack
the president to attack president trump
i think it's the opposite now